all right let's talk about this covet
situation because uh you know aoc sure
she's hanging out with the uh with the
elite you know 30 30 000 tickets
but we are told that there is this
pandemic and uh there is now a fight
which has broken out between joy reid
and nicki minaj now joy reid i don't
watch msnbc but i have referenced her
every now and again because out of all
the ridiculous clowns that are on
mainstream media and on these cable news
channels i would say joyride is probably
at the top you can get
video and still images and text of joy
reid saying one thing one day the next
thing the next day and it's not because
she's evolved it's because she's a
ridiculous partisan clown so first we've
got video from her show yesterday going
after nicki minaj nicki minaj if you
don't know she's a singer
not really my thing you know i like
frank sinatra but you know she's a
popular singer amongst the kids and joy
reid's going after nicki minaj so we're
going to show you the video and then
i'll explain why she's doing it here's
joy reid and people like nicki minaj i
have to say this
you have a platform sister that is 22
million followers okay i have two
million followers you have 22 million
followers on twitter for you to use your
platform to encourage our community to
not protect themselves and save their
lives my god sister you could do better
than that you got that platform
it's a blessing it's a blessing that you
got that that people listen to you and
they listen to you more they listen to
me
for you to use your platform to put
people in the position of dying
from a disease they don't have to die
from oh my god as a fan as a hip-hop fan
as somebody was your fan i'm so sad that
you did that so sad that you did that
sister oh my god
joy reid sister i got something to tell
you as dave rubin right over here
because you got a platform you got two
million followers on twitter these are
not the brightest people on the planet
and you've got a show on msnbc not a
great network but you've got influence
girl so what are you why are you saying
that why is she saying that to
uh nicki minaj well
you ray remember this tweet i've shown
it to you guys about 10 times let's pull
up the tweet because nicki minaj
commented on this tweet this is joy
reads uh opus right this is her most
famous tweet this is joy reid when
donald trump was president i mean will
anyone anyone at all ever fully i guess
you're saying fully trust the cdc again
and who on god's earth would trust the
vaccine approved by the fda how do we
get a vaccine distributed after this
broken trumpist nonsense has infected
everything even if biden wins my god
my god has joy reid seen what joy reid
tweeted
joy reid's got a platform joy read
better freaking you know go after joy
reid because this is crazy so then nicki
minaj uh retweeted that tweet and she
said this
a lying homophobic i'll just skip that
word i guess i can join in on the
reindeer games too right people can go
on tv and lie on me i can report on them
too right doesn't have to be truths it
can be half truths uncle tomania asks
who on earth would trust the usfda guys
at joy and read and then she retweeted
that tweet i just showed you there this
was all sparked if you you know i don't
like to do these little twitter battles
like that's not really what i'm trying
to make as the main issue here this was
all sparked by basically nicki minaj had
sent out a tweet saying that one of her
friends i think in trinidad
took the vaccine and something happened
to his testicles and she basically
literally i think his testicles got
bigger they got bigger and smaller
it was bigger big thank you
we have a series of hand motions during
the show so the guys don't have to talk
but i just got the bigger testicles
signal thank you uh so apparently this
is what nicki minaj is saying one of her
friends got big testicles after the uh
have to get in the vaccine there and uh
and then basically she was just saying
just don't be bullied into getting the
vaccine that's what nicki minaj said so
anyway i illustrate this fight not
because i want to talk about joy and
read or even care about nicki minaj
really um do i do i know any nicki minaj
songs like what's her big song
she's got a couple big ones that's what
they're telling me big is the testicles
or what all right the point is guys um
i don't like joy read i don't like aoc i
don't like joey reid i don't like gavin
newsom maybe tomorrow i'm just gonna do
a show where i'll just list the people i
don't like that would be a good show